Chewbacca actor Peter Mayhew has died at
the age of 74 the Mayhew family released
a statement that Peter died on April
30th with his family by his side in his
North Texas home Mayhew who stood seven
feet three inches tall
originated the role of Chewbacca
throughout the Star Wars saga et spoke
with him at the premiere of the force
awakens in 2015 how exciting is this for
you tonight come on you shakin I've
never seen one bigger than this and I've
seen some big ones here this is got to
be how often do you get a premiere that
runs three blocks normally the last one
we did was Episode three
it's amazing I think it's good Mayhew
retired from the Chewbacca role before
production began on Star Wars the last
Jedi only coming on to consult his
successor Jonas suet amo he told me he's
reasoning behind in though in that
wookie boot camp he told me what why he
did our certain thing why he would look
in an angle like that and and it was so
because I had done lots of study in my
own own time before that it was so good
to finally hear from the from the man
himself
why he did certain way and it helped me
tremendously to prepare for example for
this film but even more than Star Wars
Peter Mayhew was known for how much he
loved and appreciated his fans in fact a
fan design McCain he used which was made
to look like a lightsaber a little
assistance as you're walking along let's
look at this King come on now people
that was made by a fan who is a gunsmith
I need a cane to walk with and he said
pick up make it for my person to go the
only time she uses a lightsaber
yeah usually gets a boat goes
[Music]
you